AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME,
TOURIST TRAPPED.
SPRING IS JUST AROUND THE
CORNER AND TEMPERATURES ON
THE EAST COAST ARE
SKYROCKETING INTO THE SINGLE
DIGITS.
AND WARM WEATHER OF COURSE MEANS
ROAD TRIPS.
THAT'S WHY SELF-PROCLAIMED
DATA TINKERER RANDY
OLSON RECENTLY CREATED AN
ALGORITHM CALCULATING THE
QUICKEST DRIVING ROUTE
ACROSS AMERICA THAT INCLUDES
50 VISITS TO NATIONAL
LANDMARKS LIKE THE STATUE OF
LIBERTY AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
THIS IS THE PERFECT IF YOU
WANTED TO DRIVE AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND SEE A BUNCH OF
[BLEEP], THAT'S WHAT YOU WOULD
DO.
A TRIP THAT LONG IS GOING TO
REQUIRE A LOT OF EMPTY
GATORADE BOTTLES TO PEE IN.
SINCE RANDY IS SHOWING US TO
WHERE TO VISIT ON THE ULTIMATE
AMERICA ROAD TRIP, COMEIDANS,
COME UP WITH PLACES WOULD YOU TO
THE WANT TO VISIT.
LET'S PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
JESSE.
>> THE TOMB OF THE UNCIRCUMSIZED
SOLDIER.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RICKY.
>> FERGUSON.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JESSE.
>> THE MUSEUM OF LACTOSE
INTOLERANCE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALICE.
>> THE [BLEEP] PART OF
ARIZONA.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALICE AGAIN.
>> MOUTH DAKOTA.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JESSE.
>> THE MEDICINE CABINET AT
NEVERLAND RANCH.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALICE.
>> INCESTUAL SEX FLAG.
IT'S IN ALABAMA.
>> Chris: POINTS, RICKY.
>> WHATEVER PARKING LOT SUGE
KNIGHT IS IN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALICE.
>> RASCAL FLATTS, THE BAND
OR IF IT'S A PLACE.
>> Chris: OKAY, POINTS.
JESSE.
>> A STORAGE WAR REENACTMENT.
>> Chris: POINTS.